if i look back on when i was 16 and
stuff was starting to happen for me as
to now it is more difficult it's like
you have to you're putting more thought
into it and i think a really important
thing is like you're more consciously
aware rather than that that raw energy
if you're just like i'm gonna do
whatever the hell i want you know like i
don't care i'm not thinking and now as
you get older i feel like you're you're
more
calculated yeah sometimes for for a good
thing and sometimes for a bad thing
sometimes you're thinking too much
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
let's do the show
i'm gonna go to that directly
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
support for the omg high podcast is
provided in part by sunday lawn care
sunday lawn care hopes you grow a
beautiful lawn without the guesswork or
the nasty chemicals get 20 percent off
your full season custom plan and go to
getsunday.com
omghi
fellas have you started spring cleaning
yet carpets need cleaning the drapes
need dusting and your lawn you know what
i'm talking about needs mowing spring is
sprung in the global leaders and below
the waist grooming that's manscaped have
the best tools for cleaning aisle five
in your pants time to clear out your
winter bush and join the other four
million men worldwide who trust
manscaped by going to manscaped.com for
20 off plus free shipping with our code
omghi
and he knows i'm a big beer drinker yeah
good well you can have a lot of this
cool yeah there's a couple flavors
there's this the regular lager there's
also the like creamsicle flavor
nice grapefruit
there was a dude that was like uh the
guy was the uh was a brewer at stone
brewery for like 30 years so i had this
legal past i said hey man can you make
you know like mexico man they drink like
presidente and like squirt nobody drinks
squirt in the united states [ __ ]
space i love squares escort's awesome
and he goes i said can you make a beer
that that that tastes like that oh yeah
i thought i could check that one off
what about uh hibiscus
oh it goes oh yeah that's a sour one i
think they're gonna stop making that one
because
it's a little bit sour but it's really
good oh yeah yeah and then i said
what about in the summer when the ice
cream man would come that 50 50 bar
orange and they go oh the dreamsicle he
goes yeah that took my legal bat
[Laughter]
i love that i love that this is like a
really i'm not just i'm not just you
know gassing you up but this shit's
really good and we got some chicano art
on there don't ask me the name but
eventually the guy that uh is my partner
was using some of it and then we were
finding out the names because the dudes
were like hey that's my [ __ ] heart
right there
[ __ ] guy
showing up thank you super cool good
presentation
so um
awesome yeah before we get too far into
it because we just started but before we
get too into it yeah joining us on the
show today we have lou collin drummer
entrepreneur i don't know what other
titles you want but i i know you're like
the most badass drummer on the internet
i'll take that as well yeah drummer
entrepreneur i like that
i now am also a co-owner of a software
company and um called makes wave shout
out mixwave uh yeah just kind of do what
doesn't make me think what does mix wave
do um we create plugins and like
software digital instruments and stuff
like
ah there's certain names i want to say
but we can't yet but we just fly out
artists to maryland record them like
super in-depth
and you're essentially able to just go
on and like if say you're creating a
song you could have uh mario duplantier
from gojira play it play the drums like
his exact tones and everything so i've
heard of that yeah i heard you had heard
of that what about what about on all the
content on um
on on youtube or whatever you know you
know and there's a little sounds that
people use in there is also the people
do people buy those sounds too yeah i
know there's like tons of royalty free
content that comes out on there i'm that
stuff there's so many companies that do
that kind of thing but i have like
it's it's pretty fun man i took a team
from like croatia we got a team in
indonesia and a team in on the east
coast as well that does like our
graphics um but yeah we have all these
people on board that are creating just
like state-of-the-art like top-notch
okay so if somebody's out there and they
want to and they are looking to either
create a page or create their own uh
podcast they would go to you guys yeah
yeah that that works i like that it does
right yeah yeah yeah is there you want
to tell them where to where to find that
um yeah so if you go to like mixwave.net
um
right now we got tony wurster jr he's
played with like you know he has a
presidency with katy perry right now mac
miller like different when he was alive
a lot of talented people that he's
worked with got thomas pridgeon who was
like the mars volta and also like a solo
guy and then we got mario duplantier and
just released my drum pack as well
but we got some really cool stuff coming
out very soon good because you know um
my daughter mayan
you know i used to watch just i don't
know if they call it regular tv or
whatever what they call it so my dog my
daughter says you ever watch youtube and
i said nah you don't even really watch
this [ __ ] now all i watch
is [ __ ]
it's hard to turn off sometimes
but you know what i think it is is that
you know as you grow up watching tv
um and even if you watch like you know
like a fascinated with like crime and
just stories and dev stories and
mysteries and stuff like that i think
they do a better job
the content creators on youtube than
they do with the networks and uh yeah
it's like totally personable and it's
like and you can find exactly what you
want to find where you turn on tv it's
like oh i don't really like this show
but i love the show but the show's only
on for 45 minutes right you can go on
any streaming thing and just binge watch
a whole goddamn season right exactly
exactly exactly yeah like the two dudes
that uh uh man what are they the the
second asian guy and then the
um uh
what are those guys
their youtube channel yeah that's i
don't know i mean on keep going we'll
see if i can so anyway they go to some
mental institution in philadelphia where
it's supposed to be highlighted they
throw a ball down the hall this [ __ ]
ball comes bouncing back like whoever
was down there threw it back oh man oh
my gosh there's a wild [ __ ] that was
andy farrick at the end of the hall for
sure
paranormal in the paranormal world
is it the ghost brothers they're just
the first ones i turned up maybe okay
there's probably so many
you know
because i was uh
you know i don't
very difficult to talk about but but uh
um
uh mr edward van halen and i were very
good friends okay and and i would tell
him that
you know it was the family business you
know because of of of wolf and alex and
his dad and
and and everybody and i would say once
these guys just go out like the three
you man
just call called the family business
yeah yeah [ __ ] like they like they
could do everything i mean even there's
a story that
that uh the van halen was gonna was
early in their career and they were
playing out some at some
gig and they were outside smoking
cigarettes in the gut walk by with a
like a saxophone case and then david lee
ross said hey man can my friend play
your sax
and uh he says uh
does your friend know how to play sax
and he goes no but he can play any
instrument and they said guy goes i
don't know man so they went and got him
a read and they took the sacks out he
played the sax like he couldn't [ __ ]
play any anything yeah some people are
like some people are [ __ ] like that
like my sister she she's like a i guess
not jack of all trades what would you
call girl jack like a like a jane you
got to be careful
um she yeah she was that that [ __ ]
she would play she write songs on piano
and she's four years old like win the
talent show every year play clarinet
harp sax or i don't think she played
saxophone i mean that's she's on the
phoenix on the drumline like crazy stuff
yeah and now and she went to like
i don't know this is so when your family
has it who when you're when your family
has that like how far does it go back i
guess like the drumming stuff yeah which
is my musical my dad um i guess as far
as my knowledge it was my great grandpa
so is my my grandpa's
actually it's my grandma's dad on my on
my dad's side so growing up you saw
pictures and i saw and it was like piano
like apparently you know i didn't know
him um he died before i was born but he
would shred piano and play like all
these jazz clubs and stuff like that
yeah like
and then my dad like i got it naturally
from him um
he would you know my mom stayed out like
she should be holding me and i'd be like
tapping on her shoulders yeah kind of
sure of course but um but yeah my dad
played uh for for very long and um i
feel like anything that he was good at
like he he played baseball he's very
good at baseball i did that for a long
time and then drums was like the two
things that i feel like i could have
actually taken and went like full career
pick drums obviously but
um yeah yeah and what does that feel
like i mean
you know
the older i get when i was in little
league i thought i was pretty good the
older i get the i realized the [ __ ] i
wasn't as good as i thought i was and
that my friends were pretty good but i
was well you should probably say average
okay yeah yeah i was average but i
thought i was better but those guys were
better and so and some
some [ __ ] guys just
like they just had him they just got it
and like it's so cliche to say when
somebody's born for something you're
like made for that but i feel like the
older i get the more i realize that's
kind of a thing and also there's that
there's that time period in your life
where
where you're like growing as an
individual your brain's literally
growing so whatever you're doing at the
time if you're passionate about it you
happen to be passionate about it your
brain is going to like soak that up like
a sponge you're going to be
you know and that's kind of like i got
lucky found something i was super
passionate about like at a young age i'm
really thankful for that i know a lot of
people aren't
you know they'll find it later on in
life and i think that's great too but
um yeah that that young phase i feel
like is so
so powerful like so important but you
know there's people like you know just
i'm telling you this world is crazy you
know so so
there's a there's a uh orkin guy i think
he's a oregon dude a fumigation guy that
comes by my house i was coming out of
the garage and it looked like he was
walking a dog because he had that long
hose oh yeah so i rolled the window down
i said hey man i thought you were going
to let your dog piss all over my fence
you know what it was he was spraying
that stuff and then he says hey listen i
know you play i know you play guitar and
the orchid [ __ ] dude hands me a
cd of music like guitar instrumental
and i mean that dude's been with me
forever i had no idea the dude play
guitar
and if you looked at him
he i mean you might see him at a can
i don't think they have this place
anyway bobby mcgees you know four
o'clock in the afternoon
you know somewhere in the lobby and
stuff like that but but i mean in no way
would you look at that dude and think
that that guy could play guitar right
right and that's kind of a cool thing
like you know it's like closet musicians
some people call them basement musicians
like
you know a guy that has never played a
real gig in his life like
in person has been playing for 16 years
in his basement and can sit down at like
a guitar center and just go nuts on a
kid like
yo i thought i thought you were doing
like fumigation or something like you
were construction right like how the
hell are you
i know you shred drums like it's crazy
let me ask you a question so so in the
80s
um when you travel to different towns
like if you went to a hilton or if you
went to a hotel in the bar they had live
music yeah and uh it almost almost like
you know around the country they had
live music do you think that when that
because they don't do it anymore do you
think that that might have ended maybe
of those people they're having careers
or them having kids and then playing and
then playing instruments and then
creating more music right what do you
think of that i mean i feel like
because it just stopped completely like
it doesn't happen anymore yeah and
unfortunately i didn't really get to
experience that because i was born in
the night it was fun shout out 1993
my uh my gemini's out there just getting
really i don't know but if you went to
but if you went to a hotel and checked
in you could hear music right right and
then you would almost go over there
so it's enticing you're like oh like
there's probably a vibe over there yeah
i'll have some drinks like whatever i
mean i guess nowadays
it's really interesting it's turned into
like kind of niche right so it's like
you can go it's like let's go to a jazz
club tonight and like you know everybody
dresses all nice and it's turned into a
thing it's almost like reminiscent in a
way yeah but yeah i guess if that was
back and like live music was more
normalized i think that'd be really good
it'd just be there right but also also
it would probably be like you know you
got like travis scott wannabes and stuff
coming in and you're just like yo like
i'm just trying to check into my hotel
right but also i would say that you're
gonna have some predators you know
yeah
probably some weird stuff too like that
song that uh sister sledge wrote uh the
greatest dancer you know he's the
greatest they they were
they were checking into a hotel
and there was music playing and they saw
some dude dancing
and they were like oh [ __ ] this dude
gets down and they wrote that song
because they saw that dude that's
awesome
dancing it's always you never know what
inspiration is going to start right
exactly
exactly never know and
um i heard you guys talking about you're
not or you're not in a band
um
so this is always kind of an interesting
question for me to answer because i
love not being tied down i i was in a
band um called the word alive for like
five years uh we toured internationally
like probably eight nine months out of
the year and that's where i got kind of
my touring whatever you want to call it
you know i've got my feet in the door no
i think you get your legs right yeah
exactly that's that's what i was looking
for but ever since then i quit because i
just i felt like i wanted to do more and
since then i've been playing with
different rappers i play with like
playboy cardi to rufus du sol who just
won a grammy last night
for
best like i think it was electronic
house
album i want to say so so well deserved
shout out to those guys um
and then you know also have a project
with this guy named jason richardson
who's like one of the top 10 best guitar
players in the world he's just like
he's insane he's an absolute machine
he's nuts um yeah so how is that dude
he i think he's 30. jason if i got here
if i got your uh your age wrong don't
kill me don't sue me both of you [ __ ]
i've been playing every day for the
while i tried you know i sold flowers
when i was 15 to buy a guitar but i
still i stopped i play every day i
played i played today that's awesome
what kind of stuff do you usually play i
just you know i'm still trying to learn
the four songs i was learning back then
yeah
uh you know uh uh um ain't talking about
love for teacher black dog rock and roll
um play that punk music white boy yeah
train running um
like that awesome yeah for teacher man
that that drone oh dude yeah oh yeah
i mean i mean not many rock songs start
with a drum solo i know right yeah
that's a pretty good drug solo
know that in that uh in knowing you know
uh eddie and the way that that at that
period of of a band's time when
you know you start hot
and then you you know you got a couple
that are still really good just because
of the momentum but yeah but but that
well it was called 1984.
he kind of you know he built that studio
at his house and he
pretty much like just took over the
studio and said hey man you guys can't
come in here i'm working on this thing
it's almost like do or die type thing i
know you know you've been in music and
stuff like that and he's like you guys
can't have it you can't look at it you
can't hear it i got it
and there was a dude there and then he
would when the guys would come he would
give
the master to a friend of his and he
would go around to like the servants
entrance and just hang out back there
and then when those dudes left you would
come back okay
and bring it back like no nobody
nobody can [ __ ] with this except me i
kind of respect that yeah it's a
delicate thing it is it's very personal
like music's very like close you know
you hold that like yeah for example i
have all these records i'm not even
playing that i've been working on i mean
me and jason richardson got a new record
coming out soon and we've been working
on that since 2018 right and we we've
been like recently showing close friends
and family like it's finally you know
there's a couple other groups i'm
working with i'm very excited about
can't talk about but it is that thing
it's like it's so personal but it's like
it means a lot to you so you want to
throw it out there okay so so
you know he's not here but to talk about
that but when you when you're looking at
something that closely
like what are you what are you exactly
looking at like what are you guys what
are you guys listening for
i think the biggest thing especially
with jason and i actually
no it's with all music music is all
about how it makes somebody feel right
right so like if we you know jason and i
have this thing where if we listen to a
part that builds
and it comes up to a certain moment and
we don't get goosebumps we're like ah
there's something something not right
there we're not like getting chills at
that point so i think that's really
important if you can emotionally connect
with your own music like that's how it's
supposed to be because that's how you
reach other people other people
emotionally connect to it then you're
you're [ __ ] set like let's go like
that's how you right people will pay
attention whatever you do in the future
as well so
but you know what as many musicians as
as i know and we'll go through we'll go
through some of them yeah
not one of them
has ever said to me
you know when i get goosebumps or when i
hears my music played and i get
goosebumps like i know like [ __ ] okay i
got it
they they've never said that you know
it's important man that feeling like the
feeling of when you hear a song for the
first time and you're just like wow i
know i'm going to put this on repeat for
the next month yeah that feeling like
that to me there's nothing i connect
with more in life than that feeling so
we try to bring that
you know it's it's a difficult thing
like you don't know what people are
going to connect with but as long as
we're connecting with we know that's a
really good no no i know but it's a
difficult thing but you know if you
settle for less then you're just like
everybody else i think and if you get in
if you hold out and it takes longer
and then when you guys are producing it
it makes you feel that way and then as
you go through the process of it and and
start to finish it in it and it still
does that to you [ __ ] man exactly that's
got to be like the [ __ ] uh
christopher columbus settling now
for the new world because whatever you
find exactly is going to be it's going
to be a hit whoever finds it is going to
be [ __ ] solid 100 yeah yeah and and
uh did you go to concerts and when you
were younger you still go man
surprisingly i'm i know this is gonna
sound kind of uh no i understand i know
what you're gonna say religious yeah i'm
not a big fan of live music
because i feel like whenever i was
little and i was going to those shows
and stuff i get dragged to certain
things there was a couple shows i went
to that i like had such a [ __ ] blast
at but um
it was always like i want to be that
dude up there i don't be watching this
dude unless it was like somebody i
really respected can you say who they
were or you don't want to say um i mean
yeah you went to shows i think the first
show that i remember going to was this
band called the format and the singer
ended up being the singer of that band
fun do you guys remember fun oh yeah um
you would hear it and be like oh i've
heard that song a million times played
everywhere for years yeah um i'm not
going to try to say you you play you
play guitar too right yeah and how did
you start playing the guitar um so i
come from like a kind of musical family
uh my mom already was kind of musical uh
so like my mom favorite singing in the
living room my dad not at all um she
always like sang in the church choir and
stuff oh all right yeah well that's not
kind of musical that's that's how many
people start in the church a lot of
people yeah
but like on my dad's side nothing at all
like they're they're like the
engineering of side no no none of that
but that's where i got like i like his
favorite band was like yes it's like i
grew up listening to a bunch of like
progressive rock sort of funky or crazy
yes come on uh of course and then yes
split off and had a band called asia
and they had that asia had a great album
in the early 80s that did like uh um
what did they have man i can't remember
i never meant to be so i can't sing it
uh heat of the moment just one album one
album of all yes dudes that had like
nine songs seven hits crazy crazy that's
like man the 80s was such a good time
for music it's insane they were still
playing man like they weren't
there weren't you know synthesizers yet
i remember i was doing an interview on
this
i think it's latv on pico and it's a
former recording student as i'm walking
down the hall i start seeing like earth
wind and fire you know gratitude and
earth wind and fire this and a gold
record for that and i'm like hey uh is
this what we were going to find oh yeah
i said what studio
they said
uh it's back there i said can i go in
there
and then you want to go in the studio
they're not in there i said
i said i know it doesn't matter it's not
about that
yeah yeah and they let me go in there
and stand in there it's awesome pretty
[ __ ] amazing man i just did actually
wow i say just but uh in 2019
yeah i do covet just
evaporated time bro evaporated but i
went and did something uh with my
roommate elmo's company called jam card
where they recorded thriller and they
did you know frank sinatra's studio like
united recording and they have something
called a drum umbrella and it's like
literally this thing that bends down and
it comes over the drums and dude the
sound in there is so so great but it was
just so cool like you know just it's
about being in that presence you know
what's happened in this room is a drum
umbrella new is that a nude i want to
say it was an old old thanks i've never
ever in my life seen it or heard about
it except for in that studio does that
place on westlake um it's it's on uh
it's on sunset boulevard it's near like
sunset and vine because i used to live
there it was like walking distance from
that sunset sound though sunset sound is
on the it's like oh yeah if you go this
way it's sunset sound if you go this way
it's united recording okay everybody the
palladium hey you know what uh
okay
all right there's some there's some it's
funny how in hollywood like out there
there's some little just
hole in the wall
you'd walk by it a thousand times and
you'd never know what the [ __ ] was going
on in there yeah and then you realize
when you're going there what's been done
in there yeah oh yeah i mean like you're
saying earth wind and fire like yeah i
also did this record for a band called
star set and i worked with the same guy
who did like system move downs toxicity
record like all the drums and stuff and
like that was a whole nother thing but
that was sunset sound as well so it's
like just working
it is about being in that room and
feeling that energy that was there
before and you're just like damn and you
know so some some people i remember
chris rocky in the in the beginning of
his book said like
what what makes a comedian in it and a
community and i think his example was
like
did you see that and then the other
person said see what
and he says that that that makes the
difference between a comedian somebody
that said i didn't i don't know what
you're talking about yeah and then
versus somebody that says oh yeah i saw
it you know i saw it too because
everybody has a vibe whether it's you
know
musically
uh comedically like you're just getting
sent
messages from wherever totally totally
and they're here and they're hitting
yeah yeah uh um what do you think the i
mean because i remember my man little
some i mean
going to buy music going to wait and
going to ask a guy hey when is this
album supposed to come out you know
would you store by tower records uh on
sunset last night
what do you think the the future of of
um
[Music]
is it so much i mean it almost even
sounds like it's not even going to be
about bands
but more about sounds um you know what's
really really interesting is i've
noticed this kind of uh resurgence of
live music like real instruments is
coming back i mean for a while like 2005
through really like pretty recently it
was all djs rappers like that kind of
stuff and don't get me wrong like you
know there's still live instrument
elements that could be introduced into
that to make it super interesting but
there's this whole thing right now
that's coming that's that's
drummers and guitarists and that kind of
stuff that's coming back and i'm like
[ __ ] yeah dude let's go let's go but in
terms of like the you know purchasing
music that kind of thing
um obviously streaming came in i don't
think spotify any of those dudes knew
how insanely prominent it was going to
be
but you know it sucks that their payouts
that they do to artists is insanely it's
just like they're backhanding each every
one of us like personally
but
it's interesting um but who set that
system up like in the beginning you know
in the beginning of recording you know
there's like
and they used to pay people in blow was
a currency you know you go over there
and do
a dude and you you'd have to do the
right an album and he'd go this is great
and he'd hand you
some blow you know yeah and the whole
thing you know pay for play and all that
stuff like that that in the beginning
you know started i mean [ __ ] if you go
back and
you know carol kane uh carol king
um
and if you and and you know just writing
like if you go to new york they they all
sat in a [ __ ] building and sat there
and wrote songs all day and then usually
pass them over to some people i mean
they did that all all day long so it's
come from like that's the kind of the
the early man
to
to [ __ ] the [ __ ] people over
yeah because they're that'll always be
there that'll always be there [ __ ]
elvis presley's manager used to put his
[ __ ] friends down as riders oh oh
really yeah he put himself down
and he put
friends down so that they always got
paid so they got royalties and stuff so
so i guess i guess in a bit that still
can there's no
there's no master pay plan or no master
floating scale of of royalties totally
especially not you know with all the
different platforms you got spotify you
got apple music you got all that stuff
it's like it's still somewhat uncharted
territory and i can't even imagine like
you know i don't know when streaming
actually came out but it's probably 10
years ago you know maybe we can google
it or something but yeah come on it's
still pretty uncharted territory
completely so people are trying to like
navigate it and figure it out but
um they're trying to figure it out at
least they're giving like gold records
and platinum records and things for
streaming like that's cool
because think about it you know uh like
when i was a kid i'd go to target and
buy like an under oath cd or something
like a band that i would really listen
to and i would loop that cd hundreds of
times so it's like how do you
without purchasing the physical product
how do you take that right and then you
know like count the streams and i guess
they figured that out i mean i don't
know dude it's just [ __ ] sketchy man
it is it's very strange and then back in
the day like today since the grammys
were i mean whenever you listen to this
the grammys were last night then there'd
be somebody going around with [ __ ]
gold stickers and putting [ __ ] on the
albums or you know the grammy winner
yeah grammy winner so that when you went
in you know they put that [ __ ] to the
front you know so crazy yeah
you never know you just you never know
i mean don cheadle who's a friend of
mine he beat chappelle and barack obama
last night and won a grammy so
congratulations to wow there we go to
don i think spoken word so i think he
might have done a book on oh crazy i
didn't know he did that yeah oh that's
super cool i'm definitely a fan of all
his acting he's very talented yeah yeah
yeah and then over here on this side
you're looking at a three-time nominee
zero time winner
hey if they say it's a it's an honor to
be nominated i think it is dude
absolutely i think when you when you
like when i started writing jokes i
would write them on gas bills and
[ __ ] newspaper whatever i could find
and then you get nominated three times
and you don't you know i didn't win but
i didn't lose you dude yeah to get to
that point it's like it doesn't even
matter if you win like all you get is a
physical thing and that's great but like
just to even be in the conversation is a
huge yeah
are you worried about all the chemicals
you're using to keep your yard looking
its best traditional lawn care lays down
90 million that's right million pounds
of pesticides each year sunday lawn care
is different they're on a mission to
change how people care for their yards
sunday can help you grow a beautiful
lawn without the guesswork or the nasty
chemicals their custom plans include
fertilizer and everything you need to
easily take care of your lawn with
ingredients like seaweed iron and
molasses so you can feel good about it
when your kids are on it when your pets
are on it anything like that all you
have to do is visit getsunday.com
put in your address and the lawn
analysis tool will take care of the rest
they use soil data they use climate data
they create a personal nutrient plan for
your lawn and delivered to your door
when you need it for me that's that's
the best part that's my favorite part
delivered right to your door i anything
you know we live in the in the prime
area of the amazon era anything that can
show up to me instead of me showing up
to it big fan one of the things that
makes sunday great
so
for our listeners uh sunday is offering
20 off that's 20 off to omg hi listeners
full season plans start at just 129
and you can get 20 off at checkout when
you visit
getsunday.com
omghi
that's 20 off your custom plan at
getsunday.com
omghi
support for the omg high podcast is
provided in part by manscaped manscaped
has the full package you need for spring
cleaning this year that's right the
performance package 4.0 is the only tool
you need to keep your boys looking and
smelling like the fresh tulips your
partner wants to start your spring
cleaning use the manscaped lawnmower 4.0
trimmer to get the most precise shave on
your hedges did you mention it's
waterproof as well so no need to worry
about watering your grass with this one
the 4.0 and it's equipped with an led
light so you know it'll be a major asset
to your shower routine you can finish
off your grooming with the new the plow
2.0 which is a razor the perfect razor
for the finest shave on your face
because if you're using the lawnmower
point 4.0 on your balls and your face
you are doing it wrong you need to have
separate separate entities for those two
things so also important with manscape
the start of spring also marks the start
of testicular cancer awareness month
that is in april manscape has partnered
with the testicular cancer society to
bring awareness to testicular cancer
men's health and early cancer detection
it's very important manscaped is
committed to raising awareness for the
most common form of cancer in men
15 to 35
testicular cancer and giving support for
fighters survivors and families impacted
by testicular cancer as part of their we
save balls initiative so get 20 off plus
free shipping with the code omghi at
manscapes.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code omghi at
manscape.com
it's time to throw out your old hygiene
habits and upgrade your life
you know people who have uh who who like
you are very very musical um
[Music]
don't like to listen to music
it's not that they don't like music yeah
uh i was i was uh i took eddie to play
in the golf crew the tournament anthony
anderson's tournament in in uh
in palm in la quinta okay and there was
a couple guys uh that had music playing
and then uh he says to me goes hey man
you think you could
you think you could tell those dudes man
to turn their music off and i said what
because man
you know i can't listen to music like i
can't do it and i said come because just
you're in the business like you just
that was you know yeah so i rolled up on
those dudes with him sitting next to me
and i said hey man can you guys turn the
music down or off he said no off and he
goes what
i said you know my man is
my friend here
my man plays guitar and you know he just
he can't like play golf and listen to
music he doesn't want to listen to music
it's not that they hate does he hates
music he loves me right right of course
he's just not his thing and they and
they said uh
they said oh yeah you because he looked
older you know right and and and they
said you're in a band
yeah he goes yeah i'm i'm
i'm in a band
and they go abandoned are you and he
goes uh i'm eddie van halen that guy
goes
turn that [ __ ] [ __ ] off right here he
takes it throws it across the golf
course
yeah yeah
but um i think i saw a thing with him at
the smithsonian that
the last thing that he bought was like
peter gabriel's soul
i mean so that your mind so whatever you
hear
that was so long ago so that whatever
comes into your head is yours like you
don't you know in comedy it was going to
say comedians that's the [ __ ]
sit in the back of the room i always
said the next town they're they're
telling your jokes you know so that and
he decided just almost like have a clean
slate 100 you know that's like yeah like
kind of goes back to going to live music
i'm just like man like i did i started
2017 day out of high school i went so
wow i went to actually did a residence i
thought it was cool as hell but i did a
residency at the viper room with this
european group then they fired their
drummer in norway and before i turned 18
i went out to norway and played with
them and also in the uk
and that was like my introduction to
touring and i was like whoa this is
glamorous and cool and then i did the 12
passenger van thing for a minute with
the word alive after that i was like oh
this [ __ ] sucked
um but it was just like that that live
music uh after hearing it eight nine
months out of every single year and
you're just like dude the last thing
you're you get home your friend's like
let's go to the show i'm like no i'm
good it's blood right i'm good on that
but you're done
yeah yeah i just worked with an actress
that uh
was on orange is the new black for all
six years very dramatic
and i said how was that and she said
when it was over i didn't even want to
talk to a [ __ ] puppet
it's a [ __ ]
zero like so dramatic that you're like i
just don't want to
talk to anybody
see anything you know and
this is very demanding uh every day you
know for sure but but um
talk to me about it's funny man it's
funny again you know last night
we were talking about the viper room uh
talk to me about your experience in the
at the viper room
like who who was that
so i got an email um from a guy who
tried suing me uh so [ __ ] that guy i've
got a couple of homes
yeah
i'm not even going to say his names i
don't want him to get the credit but um
i got
an email from their manager found me on
youtube um i started uploading videos on
youtube when i was 16 so that was
uh
2009. so it was a while ago there
weren't many people doing it back then i
accidentally started getting a bunch of
views and i was like this is weird
i woke up one day one video had like
five thousand views out of it so so so
so let's look at what would uploading be
like back then like
it would be like um
there was no rule the while you could
just pick something out and just and
just put it up right oh yeah it was it
was totally talk about uncharted
territory
there was like
10 drummers i knew that were doing stuff
like that and it was and not not to
sound like uh like an [ __ ] but they
were um they weren't very good at it
but respect for you know the uncharted
territory yeah i'm you know i'm not the
best or anything like that i'm i'm also
learning um but i just wanted to as a 16
year old i want to like prove myself and
be like oh i can you guys are trying to
cover this song i'm going to do it but
better and i'm going to throw in my own
taste on it and that kind of thing and i
didn't even think it would get 100 views
right and now the channels are like 100
and i think it's 120 million views or
something i don't know dude it's cool
from you know i'm like very
thankful to everybody who's supporting
all that stuff but it's just like still
so weird that that's strange yeah yeah
it's so cool man and you know
um
with bands and stuff like that you know
if a band is a
well i have to you know look at it like
the bands that i watched you know
if if the band was successful
collaboratively i think they were
probably good but they didn't have to be
the best right
you know not every guy needed to be the
best just their sound was something that
people connected to yeah i mean i went
to see uh
cheap trick when they opened for kiss in
1977 at the forum
and that guy
bunny cardinals
had
[ __ ] sticks that looked like table
legs
yeah tree branches yeah he'd be playing
with these giant and i've never seen it
before but he'd do it and [ __ ] around
and then a year later they had surrender
and they had uh uh you know
all all their hits all the cheap
chickens but they were opening for kiss
and then this guy had these big ass
sticks and he played with these six so
like you know
collaboratively as a band guys could
just
just mend
everybody's talent and they just become
yeah
that's that's the beauty of a band and
again like like you nailed it perfectly
you don't have to be the best and the
best doesn't exist in music like it
frustrates me in like you know guys like
travis barker who in my opinion is the
most well-known drummer on planet earth
right like people talk about oh yeah but
can you play this but can you do that
like it's not about that like how does
travis barker make people feel when they
listen to his music or whatever that's
what matters travis barker and i've
known travis parker for probably like 12
years and then i did a thing i hosted a
thing for slash at the avalon yeah
and
i saw travis barker play
uh pretty close
and
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] was off
off of his stool like off in the air
and i remember i told him i said man
dude i mean it's just really [ __ ]
incredible man you know just an
incredible drummer and then
i saw
black sabbath at uh the sports arena and
there was a dude
that looked like jesus christ playing
drums long hair with a beard and that
what's it what's that guy's name jesus
christ
did you remember that drummer yeah yeah
totally the [ __ ] was good too man hell
yeah and they were just he wasn't he
good oh yeah he's great oh man and it's
and you know for me as a i love music
like i've
i've loved since the first time he told
me to turn that [ __ ] off
um i've just seen some
really really
uh great musicians you know and been in
the company of a lot of a lot of great
musicians and you know i you know the
guys and kiss are my friends you know
and then
when you when you go back there and you
listen to like kiss alive or the guy
that with the cat makeup on and now you
realize like
he really that well i i i don't want to
say it wasn't that
it was just a different type of drummer
than they needed right right that dude
is more a bit jazzy okay so with the
rock
they ran into some
you know we couldn't
you know it's just different speeds
right some either hindrances or like
ideas weren't measuring properly yeah
yeah yeah right and then you know that
when you put an ad in the in the paper
and this dude comes in and and you're
not fully functional as a you're not
you're not up and running you're not
kissed yet yeah and the guy starts
playing oh [ __ ] he can he he can keep a
beat you know and then when the stakes
get higher
the dude's answered and he's you know
it's a bit older and you know and then
you run into promise so but
um
oasis the the you know oasis um
they uh
they fascinate me matt because
you know i don't think those two guys
talk the brothers
talk
uh that's like such a frequent thing i
feel like with older people
yeah i mean like when you're in such a
creative relationship for such a long
time you grow
as people like where you are that's why
bands like red hot chili peppers and
stuff they've been a band for so long
the fact that they still are you know
are doing their thing like so much is
crazy
but but but in a in in a in a
in a in a band
is
is the bass player i mean they're all
equal parts
but in some bands it makes some dudes
look like feel inferior like it's almost
like they make dudes feel inferior and
then you you have a problem but i just
think
if
comedians were like bands i i don't
think
they would stay together like it's gonna
be so [ __ ] hard to stay to get to
stay in a band well i think what happens
in bands
is that it's not that anybody's more
superior or inferior or like a talent
level or like oh you contribute this or
whatever it's
i think in certain situations depending
they actually they will contribute more
to the music or they'll write everything
or they'll like that guy with this
producer is the band and then like
eventually after years and years your
brain gets warped to like well actually
um i wrote all the music so what are you
contributing you go on stage and like
you're complaining about that there's so
many different arguments and like it's
so wrong so so in in in regards to that
like when dudes are starting to create
beats
it eliminates [ __ ] three other dudes
in your head telling you i don't know i
don't like that like you know the police
would go in there and mix an album and
then one guy would be in there playing
the bass and the other guy would be in
there [ __ ] turning his part down
and turning his [ __ ] up like they just
they just would just do that all the
time it's crazy so in this world right
now
there's almost more independence more
freedom and you're and more
you can be more creative without having
through the glass
you look and see seven guys yeah just
standing there like this
judging every single move like what are
you doing you guys are staring at each
other going no i didn't [ __ ] see the
guy
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
right here
no
no so yeah so i i think you know
it's funny because
you don't want to
you don't want to
become out of touch with the way with
the way things are but as you age
it's just natural that you know i would
not be as current in your music as i was
in in the older stuff and then you know
they're like you don't know who that is
that's you know but but you know i had
in my time
you know there was some pretty [ __ ]
great
some pretty great bands oh yeah
yeah i mean it's it's funny like i'm
only 28 years old but i still i'm
feeling that now like there's music
that's super popular right now i'm just
like
if you say so
if you say so exactly
like that's cool
no respect good for you for succeeding
and like and do your thing but i'm you
know i just again it's about how does it
make me feel and i just feel like pure
and genuineness from the music i'm like
dude i like what is going on here but
again respect no no anybody who's doing
their thing like respect that's about
what it's all about when i sold my my
first show in 2002
i was unknown
and we went to abc went to warner
brothers and then we went to abc and
they bought it and i just did a show
with my daughter where
you know
i'm [ __ ] george lopez i get this
[ __ ] hollywood walk of fame i got a
[ __ ] wax museum
you know and i have to jump through
hoops
20 years later that just seems really
kind of opposite yeah contrary to i
should have been jumping through the
hoops in 2002 not
22. not now yeah yeah not now and you
know [ __ ] mr electric you know big
picture electric
is really interesting to think about
like people think if you're you know at
the top of whatever food chain you are
there's no issues there's no problems
like life's a breeze but it's like no
man i think you know until you're there
i think it's always i think you know
people think that this business is
whether it's you know easy
or
whether
they don't they just see the end result
you know i talked about big boy for 30
plus years and yesterday we talked for
half an hour i don't think remember the
last time we talked for a half hour on
the phone and we talked about that and
you know as you get older man it's like
it's like it's true man you know things
change and [ __ ] like that changes and
and and
and
you start to look for a place to land
beyond
you know beyond this like
um and i don't think that people when
they see things or have a page or have
uh something that's that's popular right
now
that they're not thinking like how do i
stay popular
five years ten years down the road right
they're just acting in the moment
because they're just loving the they're
loving the money or they're loving the
attention of of right now but the work
continues it gets i think it gets harder
the further you go down the road not
easier i think so too like and and
obviously you know i'm i'm still
young in the grand scheme of things but
if i look back on when i was 16 and
stuff was starting to happen for me as
to now it is more difficult it's like
you have to you're putting more thought
into it and i think a really important
thing is like you're more consciously
aware
rather than that that raw energy if
you're just like i'm gonna do whatever
the hell i want you know like i don't
care i'm not thinking and now as you get
older i feel like you're you're more
calculated yeah sometimes for for a good
thing and sometimes for a bad thing
sometimes you're thinking too much
um but also you know there comes a time
i think when
when
you have to make it a a hard decision
yeah like it's they people are gonna
look to you and they're gonna say so
what do you think that we should do and
then you're gonna have to make an answer
like for for you you know right for for
the artist and sometimes people make the
right
call and sometimes they don't i mean i
think i think you see it a lot right
yeah yeah it's it's crazy for sure yeah
and uh so so if if if there's a kid out
there
and
uh do you still remember when you
started playing and people looked at you
like what the [ __ ] that what the [ __ ]
look on their face like when you started
to play they'd be like holy [ __ ] i do
and it's really funny you say that um
yesterday i was having a conversation
with my friend
and i i just unlocked this memory that i
totally forgot happened and i think i
was 11 or 12 i just started playing
drums i started when i was 11. like i
would my next-door neighbor his name is
frank he would um
he would open his garage door frank
becerra oh man uh [ __ ] open his
garage door play drums just loud as [ __ ]
the whole neighborhood just like shut up
you know but i walked over there one day
and i was just like yo dude can you
teach me something and he taught me
and i was like hooked right so every day
he'd open his garage door for the next
two weeks i'd be like hey can you teach
me something and then he would just be
eventually he was like dude like go away
you know
respect not actually but but i started
mowing lawns for like nine months around
my neighborhood got my first drum set
was like 350 dollars and i was like i
thought it was you know it's like
a car or something i guess i was so
stoked but um
but think about what that was though i
mean oh yeah i mean i saw flowers to buy
a guitar yeah
so that was like a 95
in san fernando at castle so so it um i
wish i still had it i don't have it you
still have your drums no no i actually
don't remember what i think i might have
given them to somebody or something but
i can't remember i know i didn't sell
them i know that
yeah yeah yeah because they're they were
really good like well [ __ ] nobody
won't mind but you know
in long beach um
i did a show in long beach
and um
it's where the carpenters went to school
you know what we're treating karen
carpenter which are [ __ ] tons of hits
and behind glass
was her drum kit i was sick and it's
just a little three i don't know how
many five the symbol
and with her sticks and then it said
lead
sister she had this famous t-shirt that
said lead sister on there and and um it
was behind glass and i remember i was
standing there man
and i don't know how long the [ __ ] i was
standing there like yo hey hey you got
to go man i just was just [ __ ]
fascinated by it's kind of getting lost
it's not same as like being in that room
where the magic happened you just see
something you're like you instantly your
brain connects
like wow that was written on this like
all that song i've listened to a million
times yeah yeah that's
that's the power those are her yeah oh
yeah
it's been it's been in my life
i mean
my whole life
so like frank like that dude like you
know what what would have happened if
frank didn't live next door to you i
mean what would happen
if he didn't open the [ __ ] garage his
garage door and you didn't hear that
shin it's something i think about i've
thought about for sure he was one who
showed me um rest in peace joey jordison
from slipknot um i remember like when he
he realized he's like okay this kid
really likes drums right so you gotta
come and see inside and see this dvd
joey jordison playing this
drum solo where he like is like
going like this and he's coming um
upside down and playing just like
just like crazy stuff you're like what
the hell it just absolutely blew my mind
i didn't know human was capable of that
right so it was that moment that i you
know i just i was playing baseball at
the time and i was like nah
because i never had any passion in
baseball but i was really i felt like i
was very good at it but i just felt
nothing and drumming was what made me
feel something so
so so in that um
in what you just did right there is
there is there a pattern
is it like how do drummers remember that
like how do they remember that well uh
the joey jordison pattern um it's either
i call it four over two which is like a
ten there's like a template yeah yeah
two on the feet so
that's my feet ah
okay like or two over two
and you can combine two over two and
then four over two
you know like that kind of then you just
move that around a little drum lesson
for you guys yeah if you're bored at
work just sit there and just do this
just really slow and then get really
fast at it yeah
that's awesome
you know i was uh
i dropped so so uh you know
i know if i come i know everybody um i
was i was carlos santana in at the house
of blues and then cindy blackman santana
played for lenny kravitz and she was
there as we were talking with her pad
yeah and warming up as we're just you
know me and my daughter just talking you
know
and you know but i remember seeing her
do this volkswagen commercial um
with her fro and just this and you're
just like man like i mean the drones are
[ __ ] impressive man
it's um
the older i get and the more i dislocate
things and break things and i'm just i'm
like people are always like oh it's it's
such a physical i'm like it's not it's
not that physical and then as you get
older you're like oh [ __ ] it is pretty
physical so so as you're playing
in your head are you going through the
numbers or are you playing
freely like
not at all there's there's um
so if you guys listen to the jason
richardson project
it's um
very technical very fast a lot of
absolute chaos but it's syncopated
between me and him and it's very
intentional
but it's
there's a lot happening
we're never you can't think about like
patterns like i was just doing yeah of
course it has to become a second
language that you speak where you don't
think about it because if i'm thinking
four over two two
three three like i'm i'm screwed from
the get go it has to become just
something it's just like how we're
talking right now like you don't even
think about it yeah uh uh uh like a
horse in the the jockey
yeah yeah i mean
that too the dude the dude could be
sitting on a a wooden horse
and practicing and doing this [ __ ] but
then you get on a real horse oh yeah
yeah no no horses scott hey listen but
i've seen a lot of uh
i've seen a lot of success and i've seen
a lot of failure
and um i decided that uh
that i believe that in order to be
successful that you would have to
isolate yourself from other people
so that a lot of things that they
decided to do or even if you relied on
somebody that was unreliable like that
would [ __ ] your life up yeah like how is
this
how is this person gonna
you know not show for me not show for us
and then we get affected by it yeah you
know so um i haven't talked about this
so the guy that i grew up with a guy
ernie that i named my my uh
character after all my first show uh
passed away
probably by the time this airs maybe
like a month you know and he was my
oldest friend my first friend and uh it
was extremely difficult to to think that
this guy was not going to be around
anymore but when i look back and
thought about him
he put me on my path he was my frank he
was the guy that that said let's go sell
flowers and buy a guitar he was a guy
that said in 10th grade there's a guy at
kennedy high school that's doing
stand-up let's go to a comedy store he
was the guy that said let's go golf
on christmas day and he was a guy that
turned me onto richard pryor so you know
whether
we were
as close in the end as we were in the
beginning
really is
not the point the fact that that was the
dude that put me on four paths that i'm
still on yeah you know like that guy
opening his garage door yeah yeah
which is so funny because really sorry
for your loss yeah but those those
people are like so important and and
half the time they might not even
realize it you know i never really
powerful hey man the [ __ ] muse
you know him opening his garage well
first of all you know when you come from
where we come from
when somebody's garage door was open
they meant they were home you know like
they were like i i knocked uh and i
don't nobody answered was the garage
door open he's not home you know
everybody the first thing they did was
open the garage door i mean how many
great musicians have come out of that
[ __ ] uh
just
track home laid cement exactly what
peoria arizona dude that was like track
home like that that cement they lay in
the garage that's just you know
imperfect but in the sound of all that
[ __ ] matters it's uh
because there's i feel like there's that
burning desire to to
prove yourself if you if you have that
passion then you eventually it turns
into
you know maybe this language that you
speak really well and then you have this
desire to prove yourself for like you
wanna you wanna
back then when you're young you're super
ignorant to life like back then i wanted
to be one of the best i wanted to be
like a household name drummer and right
um
yeah i mean that kind of that kind of
inspiration is is really powerful and
you can't you can't really
uh
forcefully create that so and when
you're in the ernies or the franks like
you know that's like and when you play
baseball um
when you play baseball how did that how
did that feel to you too to
you know i i mean to be good at to be
good at baseball and to you know
just not like it at all yeah yeah it was
uh
my dad um my parents uh divorced when i
was three or four years old and my um
my dad wanted me to do it uh just you
know i understand why
of course yeah yeah and uh
i can't remember how many years i did it
but i pitched and i did first base if i
wasn't pitching right whatever um
and i just remember like in between each
season
[Music]
is kind of embarrassing to admit but
like i remember one time my stepdad and
my mom come into the kitchen they're
like hey like you know we signed you up
for another another league and i just
started crying i literally started
crying i was like i
do not want to do this at all and then
um
i'm trying to remember why i think it
was just because i my mom saw that i was
busting my ass to get my first drum set
for like almost a year yeah and uh i
like pulled together these crazy
resources to get this kid i think she
saw that passion rather than
um just me being forced to do something
but also but also i think maybe parents
made a connection to music of drugs and
[ __ ] ods and [ __ ] running away
from home yeah and [ __ ] like you know
you know if you see your kid with a
a book
then you go hey cool
is gonna be a professor yeah but you see
him with some [ __ ] drumsticks you're
like
that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah not in this
house you know it's right yeah i think i
think the parents have to
you know almost even that's hard to say
because it's not every kid but then you
can't say which kid it might be that's
the thing and that's what terrifies me
about potentially being a parent someday
is like i think me deep down who i am
like in my soul i've never been a drugs
dude like i don't really do that i i
enjoy drinking and stuff but like all my
friends know if there's drugs i'm like
no i'm good but like you do your thing i
don't judge like your thing but how do
you instill that in like a kid yeah you
know especially like where i come from
where i'm around that stuff a lot
it's like i don't know if you can and i
if my if my parents did subliminally and
i don't really i'm not conscious of it
like you know thanks
thanks but you know what i think it's
it's i think it's in the approach like
you know
um
if they [ __ ] scream at you or make
you feel ignorant and stuff like that
then you'll rebel against [ __ ] like that
but if they say to you like
listen which you know i don't mind if
you if you're into this i don't know if
you're into that
just you know just be careful yeah you
know these things are out there you know
mom i know and it's like no you don't
know [ __ ] you haven't been out
there yeah yeah you know i've talked to
people and people say you try to you
know say like
give me advice and stuff like that
doesn't matter i'm 60 years old i've
i've seen
every
comedian that's been around i've known
comedians
i mean
richard brown was prince richard pryor
and i grew up you know
idolizing them and all the guys that i
idolized became my friends you know i
remember yeah i was flying
from
back from columbus ohio with kiss on the
plane we're flying back to van nuys and
and paul and i were sitting across from
each other and i said is this it and
he's like i think so man he goes i think
it's just that there's just so many
[ __ ] injuries and they're at that age
that i mean did they think they would be
70 years old in makeup climbing those
[ __ ] stairs yeah doesn't matter i
don't give a [ __ ] sometimes there's ten
stairs sometimes there's five stairs
but when you get older
it's harder to climb those [ __ ]
stairs for sure and those dudes like he
even was the first one that said to me
like
whatever issue you have
you leave your problems at the bottom of
the of the stairs oh that's cool and and
you just go and do your thing you know
his 70th birthday party
um
at the roosevelt grove was there taylor
hawkins was there
and you know those dudes i did the the
grammy nominations in 2008
uh
man i was pretty [ __ ] crazy that date
matt it's amy winehouse documentary if
anybody wants to hate me more
than than you pop but you know uh but
i'm a comedian but but um
those were those were good dudes man
[ __ ] there was a you know you just
you just never
you just never really know man it's very
very true i i um
everybody whenever somebody passes away
it's like everybody goes to oh with this
moment i experience with them it's just
like natural as humans what we do but
um
i played some festival
i don't remember where i was with my old
band um and foo fighters was headlining
we played
a few spots before
and i just remember like i never got to
speak to taylor personally but i
remember like out of my trailer
obviously there's a window whatever
pulled the curtains i just saw him
walking and he stopped to talk to some
people and i was like holy [ __ ] like i
just like fanboyed from a distance you
know yeah and i i've had a
a few moments of like that that fanboy
stuff that's like yeah you don't forget
it i mean that was i must have been that
must have been like six seven years ago
now and yeah it's powerful moment you
know what man if i would give you any
advice i would give you
the advice of whenever you see
a moment like that go over and say hello
yeah yeah and i think
most of the times i've been in that
situation i've always done that this was
like if i came out he'd look like he was
no no no you know what i mean yeah of
course i but but but definitely yeah
i've seen some people that i've seen
that you know i kind of even knew you
know not even not even just maybe actors
or or
somebody and never
i should have gone and said hello and
then never saw him again right you know
and i think that it's a it's a good rule
to follow whether you're in [ __ ]
music or comedy or or whatever yeah he's
somebody in the market and they're over
there and they go oh i know that person
just go and say hey what's up bad good
to see you oh what are you doing
and then that's it yeah because you you
don't you don't know yeah you know
yeah your life is very sensitive and
also if if um
if people are out there like listen i
might not be good at guitar you play you
play
do do whatever like you said like do
whatever you're passionate about
like don't give a [ __ ] don't let anybody
stand in your way
and don't let anybody discourage you
from from anything and just follow your
[ __ ] passion that way you're not some
[ __ ] in a norm sitting by
yourself
looking outside wondering what your
[ __ ] life would have been like if you
had just done this or done that and also
too like something that i i get
i'm sure you get this all the time too
uh like i get approached with people who
are like i haven't found my passion yet
but
you know it's like i i feel for those
people because i've had moments where i
question it certain things but like i
don't know i guess what i'm trying to
say is don't be discouraged to those
people who might not have found their
passion like don't be discouraged
because like you know life is short but
life's also long like this it's never
too late if you find something in your
40s like [ __ ] get after you know what
they you know what they you know how we
say in the 70s they would say what would
you do for free
ah
yeah i love it i love that they go what
would you do for free man would you
[ __ ] tell jokes for free if you had
[ __ ] yeah i would would you dig a ditch
for free [ __ ] you um
yeah but that's correct kind of a simple
you know what would you do for free man
yeah like and then you know i had uh
people tell me you know my grandmother
was up my ass the whole thing about
learning electronics was kind of an
electronic industry and then i had this
girlfriend that was like you know you
need to go and get a job and do this
[ __ ] and i've done stand-up when i was
18 back then
and between both of them they got me to
go to [ __ ] night school oh wow really
yeah
uh valley college over there on in in in
the valley over the valley college i
went the first night i went
when the first time i went and the
teacher started talking
if my life had flashed in front of me
all it was was all the times i [ __ ]
around with my friends and didn't pay
attention and joked around and didn't
pay attention to school i was way over
my [ __ ] head and i knew that i was
so i sat there and i i and i just
[ __ ] was zoned out and started
thinking well what would i do for free
because clearly this is not going to be
it
yo
i'm not going to [ __ ] come back here
and i'm not going to get up and leave in
the middle of class
and and the whole thing was my life
flashed
before my eyes but i hadn't done
anything yet
and then
the the teacher said okay so we're going
to take a little 15-minute break
and everybody come back and i went to my
car and i took off
and i said because i said to myself
what would i do for free and it wasn't
[ __ ] electronics yeah and then i went
and started to go back to the the comedy
store the comedy store in different
places there you go yeah you chased that
that feeling that you had and then i was
then i was i was a i was a bit of a
quitter
and um
my baseball coach told me in high school
that
i was a quitter and that when [ __ ] got
tough i quit and he wanted to see where
i would end up because you know quitters
don't end up anywhere but [ __ ] at the
bottom and i said really he's like yeah
really and we were [ __ ] like this
close [ __ ] face to face i looked at
my friends and you know you're [ __ ] a
student you're a senior in high school
fighting with your baseball coach and
your nose the nose and the dudes were
like they're [ __ ] like
you know yeah and then when i started to
play golf and as difficult as it was
i quit when it got tough and then it
[ __ ] dawned on me that
that [ __ ] told me that when [ __ ]
got tough i was gonna quit and he was
right and i went years later after that
and went and saw him after baseball
practice and apologized to him wow for
for the way i treated him and that he
was right and once i knew that
then you couldn't get me to stop doing
comedy regardless of what what what
happened yes or no like hit or miss i
wasn't gonna quit
and you know now when you have kids and
like you know you said like you know as
you we see time go
that
instead of telling somebody they're
wasting their time
just tell them they need to just
focus on the on the one thing that they
love yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's i
love that yeah it's cool that you went
back and saw him you know what to tell
you the truth i don't think i could have
[ __ ] lived
if i didn't go on
and and and you know in mexican families
you know that or maybe a lot of other
families if you
have a brother you get in a fight with
your brother and they'd go
your brother like hey man [ __ ] you and
they go what happened to your brother oh
man you know i don't have a brother you
know like they don't talk for 30 years
because for the fact that they just
can't go over and say hey man i was
wrong i have to apologize right so so so
for me it was the first time in my life
that
that i ever went to somebody and uh and
apologized
and there's people out there that you
know they listen to this stuff and they
love to paint they love to draw they
love to do whatever but as long as you
breathe you have a chance to make
[ __ ] every day better yeah
you know no no guru no no [ __ ] but i've
seen some you know
i saw some [ __ ] great music like i
listened to music every day i saw
[ __ ] uh
you know i saw kiss early i saw van
halen early i saw black sabbath i saw
you know ted nugent you know ted nugent
are buddies dude he's [ __ ] hard right
yeah i'm [ __ ] left and they're like
and they're like you be friends with
that [ __ ] i said hey man
it's the music yeah yeah it's not about
politics
that's what's cool about it is like
regardless of who you are you can still
connect on something mutually like
people who don't even speak the same
language right like bts who's like k-pop
you know i've done some some covers of
their stuff that like ended up doing
doing well on the internet kind of thing
but
that's like testament right there i
remember uh
certain somebody sent me um this this
banner like 2018. you got to check this
out uh you should cover it like do it on
your on your stuff and i was like i'll
listen to it
and i listened to i was like this is
good like there's a song called fake
love by bts like this is good music
[ __ ] name okay can you you can't even
understand what they're saying because
it's in korean can you can you explain
kpop
yes yes and i will probably
partially butcher this but i ended up
getting involved with bts's they they
have this game app and like the ceo
invited me out to see them in new jersey
and i met bts's manager and um my good
friend sawan kim who was like in the
first generation of k-pop he's like this
amazing guitar player we went and did
that together and we're still in touch
blah blah blah but basically k-pop
it just exploded
in 2018 i want to say like officially
exploded right because they started
blending
um english and with it but i mean the
the all the the guys they they look uh
pristine they get like surgery done and
like all that stuff they're very like
you know girls love these dudes right um
and then the music is modern uh you know
the korean government they
i believe
can you show me
so so
but they're young cats right yeah i
wanna go get their they go have surgery
down early yeah i mean there's there's a
lot of uh there's a lot of controversy
around it because people there's like
some negative connotations you know
because it's like you're getting like
surgery done but like at the end
so like these dudes are all really
talented too like they're insanely good
singers slash rappers they they dance
while they're doing all this stuff and
their productions i've seen them three
times live and it's always like my
friend has like whatever tickets or like
when they yeah you know and it's just
crazy like it's it's uh it's such a cool
movement and i'm telling
i'm talking i felt like i was in
the sixties or something watching the
beatles
like
it was crazy they finally come out and
girls are on
fainting
singing all the lyrics in korean they're
white girls i'm like yo
this is crazy this is next level and
they sell out like stadiums in 30
seconds how is that how does that what
what's the um
what
if you were somebody's mat what's the
what's the [ __ ] trail of that like
it's a good cause you got american girls
right so american girls know they're
singing the songs and it's
it's in korean in korean it's impressive
isn't that the thing that's that really
is pretty but i think that's the thing
about music is it's
like undefinable like if it just hits it
hits it hits you and your heart hits you
in wherever that you feel it and it
doesn't matter i don't think it matters
and i think that's one thing about them
is their music is actually really good
and like they're i mean if you watch
their music videos like even back when
they're first popping off
it's insane like you can you know the
korean government's involved they
obviously like you know their label
funds everything and it's
next level i mean the floors are falling
piece by piece and like every single
five seconds looks like a two hundred
thousand dollar music video [ __ ]
amazing but just boom boom boom stacked
so
they they know what they're doing and as
time has passed i mean you know they
just the grammys yesterday they had like
um one of the guys was just like olivia
rodrigo and they have you know them with
like just
it's all lined up and it's set up
they're they're the biggest band in the
world yeah they are and um
it's yeah oh yeah yes do they win
grammys
i don't know if they wanted yesterday
but i just saw that uh so you know what
two million followers on instagram
that's crazy right behind me
the uh uh but uh
yeah man it's cool i don't think you
need to be a grammy winner to
to being him to be an influential
[ __ ] hell or not at all
it's awards you know that
right but it is but it is something uh
you know what i'm gonna
i'm gonna check it out because you
should you should if you did like a
reaction video to you reacting to a bt
sound it would explode
i'll say it here first
all right all right i'm gonna do that
yeah
i'll do that i'll do that yeah but but
but uh it's interesting mad because um
you know
you see all these things like you know i
remember [ __ ] going to the may
company and buying
you know the uh concert tickets and they
would show you a a
a pattern of the the arena and they
would say the lady would say well we
have you know some of these
you know we have some here have you ever
got a four we have two here and we have
four over here and it's amazing how
how just as time you know time has no
you can't see it yeah i mean you can
feel it but you can't really see it and
how things have gone from like
doing that
to you know bt and the government being
behind it and just
making sure that whatever they do is
just of the highest
it's solid and it's so genius too like
if you really analyze it you sit there
and you think about it it's like okay if
the government spends a few million or
what i don't know what the budget is and
i don't even know if this is true it's
just from what i've heard speculation if
they spend like a few million dollars
whatever it is and they get
wanted like the biggest band in the
world think about all the influence that
that's going to gather around the world
i mean think of all the people that
travel to south korea or buy all these
products i mean they got to
hundreds of million dollars in merch
sales alone
and it's all like people go to korea now
because it's where bts or blackpink
which is the the female version of that
who that's my biggest youtube video i
have is a black pink cover is it real
yeah it's like six and a half million
views or something like it's crazy it's
it's not crazy i love it i back it up no
no i mean but it's it's just it's cool
it's and we're not doing it here yeah
you know here when i was in uh you know
seventh grade they i mean they pretty
much cut music out of all of the schools
when in reality they shouldn't be
endorsing that or doing what like south
korea does it's putting some money into
music into musicians and then
you know they're doing it right and here
we are taking [ __ ] away from the schools
and from kids that could be talented
yeah and it's like influencing
generations you know it's really it's
really interesting yeah yeah
but i you know some of their music is
really good i feel like the stuff that
they're putting out now is a little bit
more
catered to
it feels less genuine and
the fans might
tear up no no no no no no no but listen
i just got to be honest yeah
but those are the things that change i
mean you know as you go i mean and i'm
probably sure the demand of new music is
is
is
high yeah that it's just you know
clearly
um
reaction video george lopez reacts to
bts people okay
i'm gonna do that and who's your
favorite baseball player when you when
you uh
i would say
so i grew up in arizona i remember
watching like 2001 world series um it
was like randy johnson kurt schilling
we're like the two pitchers
um
i guess
uh what was his name
was a man
101 102. yeah he had that bird that
exploded
such an iconic i mean that that's like
one in a billion yeah that's you know
crazy i see all those guys in golf and i
playing golf tournaments you see those
you see those
are [ __ ] great
i would hope so you know i know it's
like way different things once a
champion i always say once a champion
always champion yeah [ __ ] how much time
has gone by yeah do you remember who was
it uh uh
we were saying
um i was thinking uh craig council that
was his name he had a crazy batting
stance where his his bat was like up
here yeah he became he became a manager
he managed the marlins won championships
yeah it was like steve finley
um louise gonzalez randy johnson kurt
schilling craig council like that team
that was when i was the most interested
in luis gonzalez
yeah he had that like super wide battery
like his leg would come super out you're
like what the hell and he just crushes a
home run
that was it when did they become was
arizona
what year did they say
yeah i gotta say this beer is very good
it's good isn't it yeah
i'm gonna need a pallet or two
deliveries
um by the end of the day that's cool
yeah dude we we're digging uh um
[Music]
baseball too man but those are the two
things you know [ __ ]
baseball and music
yeah it's been a while since i've cared
about baseball like a very long time
but i think you know my dad had a lot of
influence on that when i was younger
and uh once i found drums it was just
it's like i started skateboarding
drumming all the time yeah yeah and then
i stopped skateboarding so i'd hurt
myself and i couldn't drum so i was like
i gotta get rid of this then yeah
uh i i didn't do anything like
like substantial but i'm all my friends
know i'm milking yeah i'm definitely
good
i'm like a walking disaster like i've
broken tons of bones
like
literally from head to toe every part of
me i've injured some way shape or form
so i'm just i'm that dude who always is
hurt yeah yeah well this is [ __ ]
awesome man yes yeah dude uh thanks for
having me yeah man thanks for coming by
brother that was [ __ ] really great
awesome do you wanna tell the people
where to find you follow subscribe and
yeah um yeah so if you search uh luke
holland drums it should pop up somewhere
i guess instagram is luke holland with
the second d um youtube is lou calling
drums
uh tick tock twitter facebook that kind
of thing um
yeah thanks to any of the fans that are
watching now and
any new fans if you guys want to check
out some crazy super technical stuff uh
the jason richardson material is crazy
um i got a lot of stuff that's in any
genre any form and i feel like that's
the beauty of being a drummer is you're
limited to nothing like that's that's
what i like that's exactly that's great
yeah yeah
cool thanks for coming out thank you
guys
yeah matt right on awesome
you